y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ellas niñas no sé si en su nombre real
tampoco sé su apellido o cuántos años
tienen o si le gusta la pizza o el asado
a nina de compre casi todos los días
durante 4 años porque su local estaba a
20 metros literal del edificio en el que
yo vivía
ni la conoce mis hijos les hizo upa nos
hizo reír y generalmente me fiaba
me fiaba fuerte un día me lleva a fiar
400 pesos antes de las vacaciones de
tres semanas sabiendo que cuando yo
volviera obvio le iba a pagar
a mí me intriga enormemente el mundo
interno de las personas que piensan que
sienten que quieren lograr que les
importa que los hace felices
me gustaría charlar y conocer a un
montón de personas que ni siquiera se
imaginan que a mí me llama la atención
saber cómo ven el mundo cómo es su mundo
desde chica me importa conectar con las
personas con las que me cruzo en la vida
de una manera profunda aunque si un
instante aunque sea efímero a mí me
importa lo que las personas tienen para
compartir y se los vamos a ver es una
oportunidad única de descubrir algo que
ni siquiera sabía que existía de hecho
si pudiera elegir un superpoder me
gustaría poder ver el mundo desde los
ojos de otras personas
sabía que alguna usted está pensando
esta piba está loca o sea viendo tantos
superpoderes elegir ese
la cuestión es que esta forma que tengo
de ser me lleva a generar vínculos
cercanos con un montón de personas en el
trabajo en el barrio con las personas
que viajo en el subte con el chofer de
la línea 71 el pelado que tantas veces
me lleva a la facu con el quiosquero con
el verdulero con el delivery del helado
a mí me gusta conocer a las personas y
en general aunque no se dan cuenta a la
gente le gusta hablar de sí misma pero
combina no me fue tan fácil porque
siempre estaba con cara de enojada y
gritándole a todo el mundo
sin embargo poco a poco se fue aflojando
conmigo y se fue generando una relación
casi cercana aún sin conocer mucho la
una de la otra y conversando sobre los
hechos visibles o más fácilmente
conversables el clima un producto nuevo
si estaba cansada
cambiar un suburban sido
por supuesto que me encantaría conocer
mucho más sobre nina cómo piensa
haciendo que tiene una cultura tan
diferente a la mía
cómo se siente en nuestro país porque
trabaja sin parar qué onda la mafia
china
como nos ve como sociedad como me ve
y si fue el mi hija o que le dije el
primer día cuando entré a comprar que
significa hola en chino mandarín o si
presentarme con mi nombre en chino
taiana que significa sol fue lo que
generó que ella entienda que yo le
proponía una relación amigable como
clienta efímera pero profunda la
cantidad de veces que intenté ahondar en
conversaciones con ni nada es
innumerable y hasta a veces ha sido
frustrante
la cuestión es que yo no hablo en chino
más que las palabras que me enseñen y
ella no habla muy bien español o inglés
como aquella vez en pascuas donde
directamente le pregunté lina jesús o ni
la duda y así me enteré que mina es
cristiana
hace un tiempo me mudé de esa casa y por
varios meses no vi a ni ná
pero hace unas semanas atrás me la crucé
en la puerta de su local
y nos dimos un abrazo con una alegría
con un cariño que no solo puedo explicar
ahí me di cuenta que yo ni ná
la quiero posta y estoy segura que ella
me quiere a mí lo sentí en ese abrazo
que me significó más que cualquiera de
las conversaciones que podríamos haber
tenido
me preguntó
cuando fue la última vez que abrazaron
al chino que les vende el supermercado
cuántas veces nos perdemos de
relacionarnos con otros solo porque no
compartimos el mismo idioma la misma
cultura la religión la ideología
política o un supuesto estatus social
son trabajos que nos autoimponemos
los seres humanos creamos la realidad en
la que vivimos el tema es que nos
encanta construir muros que nos dividen
realidades en las que nos movemos
habitualmente sin cuestionarlas
etiquetamos a quienes nos rodean y a
nosotros mismos
generando falsas certezas para sentirnos
a salvo
y en realidad solo nos quitan la
posibilidad de expandirnos de expandir
nuestra experiencia del vivir
yo considero que los seres humanos
tenemos un exceso de conciencia de
existir en sociedad
la conciencia de existir en sociedad es
aquella desde donde desarrollamos
nuestra vida cotidiana desde donde
tomamos decisiones
elegimos caminos construimos nuestro ser
social y el contexto en el que nos
movemos desde allí me construcción de mí
se relaciona con tu construcción de voz
y definimos el tipo de relación que
tenemos o que vamos a tener
algunas personas estén adentro de este
contexto y otras personas quedan afuera
esta dinámica que tenemos los seres
humanos desde la conciencia existirá en
sociedad es la que como decía antes
construyen muros nos dividen
no está poniendo capas
y cuando me refiero a que tenemos un
exceso de esta consciencia es porque me
parece importante que recordemos que
estas capas que nos definen en relación
con otros son construcciones
construcciones que realizamos nosotros
mismos los seres humanos
por supuesto que están relacionadas con
la evolución con nuestro devenir como
humanidad pero que en exceso
forman capas y capas y capas que
finalmente generan un rollo enorme mucho
rollo
yo creo que hasta el donde menos lo
esperamos podemos conectar con el amor y
no me refiero al amor romántico no digo
que salgamos de acá y nos pongamos todos
a chapar tampoco
pero los invito a sacarse el rollo a
darse la oportunidad de que les deje de
importar cuánto tiempo hace que conocen
una persona o en qué profundidad si son
iguales o distintos o bien el tipo de
relación que deberían tener con la
persona por el ámbito en que sea esa
relación
estoy segura que hay alguien en el
trabajo en el barrio en el gimnasio
en la clase de cerámica en el
supermercado que haría que su vida sea
distinta si se abrieran a la experiencia
de vincularse con él o ella
sácate el rollo que importa si el otro
habla cree o piensa distinto no nos
cambia en nada
aquellas coincidencias que tenemos con
otras personas sin embargo son las
diferencias que tenemos las que al
reconocerlas e incorporarlas nos
permiten evolucionar no vine acá a
predicar a que piensen o sean como yo
interesada en el mundo interno de las
personas
soy una chusma básicamente que le saco
conversación a todo el mundo pero que
con niña no pude porque no hablo en
chino
en serio la conexión con otras personas
abre siempre posibilidades porque
siempre hay algo para aprender
exponernos al mundo de aquellas personas
con las que compartimos espacios amplia
en nuestro propio mundo
y no necesitamos justificar los vínculos
que creamos
no necesitamos razones para querer nos
podemos querernos porque sí
sácate el rollo
todos parados así como están todos
parados
los invito a que conecten un segundo con
esa persona que tienen al lado con esa
persona que no conocen conectan un
segundo a través de un abrazo y un
abrazo en cruz de par a par de será ser
sostenido fuerte se abrazaron
y se abrazaron
si ya se abrazaron se pueden volver a
sentar
ahí está
la profundidad de los primeros de un
abrazo
abrimos a un otro implica cierta
vulnerabilidad pero la recompensa es
inmensa
les prometo que ese abrazo
les va a quedar impregnado en el cuerpo
y el espíritu para siempre
es lo que me pasó a mí con el abrazo de
niña
cuántos problemas evitaríamos cuántas
oportunidades se abrirían
si validamos primero a quien tenemos al
lado valorando lo como persona como ser
humano más allá de cualquier etiqueta
social religiosa idiomática cultural
religiosa con todo lo que eso conlleva
quienes nin en sus vidas
a quién representa
con quien podrían mejorar el vínculo o
darle la oportunidad
a quien podrían cambiarle la vida y que
se las cambio a ustedes
con rollos no nos podemos relacionar
libremente
yo creo que sin rollos podemos cambiar
nuestra vida y hasta podemos cambiar el
mundo
empezando por abrazar a nuestras niñas
sácate el rollo sí sí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]